ciao a tutti benvenuti solita stress
oggi nuovo video a trendissima richiesta
come sempre non so perché era durato
così tanto la mia voce ma sono contenta
che vi piaccia
allora questo è un nuovo video esame era
in cui mangerò del ghiaccio e mi è stato
richiesto tantissimo dopo che ho fatto
la reazione al video in cui c'erano
degli asiatici che mangiavano il
ghiaccio pervicace un nuovo trend su in
streaming generale online in cui ci sono
degli asiatici comunque statisti cortese
e mangiano il ghiaccio e mangiano più
che altro con del liquido dentro allora
dove ho fatto appunto la razzano quel
video e in migliaia
mi avete chiesto di farlo anch'io allora
non ho fatto il tempo di preparare quei
consigli che preparano loro pratica il
ghiaccio con del succo però lasciato un
bel like se volete che dal prossimo
voglio proprio prepararle magari foggia
una sembra con quelli però ho preso nel
ghiaccio quindi dei cubetti di ghiaccio
a forma di cuore e poi ho preso della
frutta congelata e questa la usiamo in
genere per fare e frullateli smoothie la
mattina per consistenza scongelando
perché è da un pò qua per piazzare tutto
l'album computer è tutto
ap è comunque perdente di riforme di smr
da un sacco che non li facevo se avete
sensibilità i diritti
forse vi può dar fastidio questo video
non lo so io i denti abbastanza
sensibili hanno tantissimo però da poco
abbiamo fatto la challenge unitalsi del
corato in cui dopo mentre il ghiaccio
alla fine però più nella mia testa è
fatto che mi facesse male i denti perché
poi una volta che lo mastica watt
non mi faceva veramente male i denti
posso farla fare un bel tempo in piazza
vediamo mater e ora poi mi sento male si
staccano i denti non so comunque se
appunto per i denti sensibili
non so se mi può dare fastidio io e
video che ho visto erano belli da vedere
con quella rilassante sentivo monte
piazzo che si frantumava bello che anzi
quindi non so se sarò bravo abbastanza
come gli asiatici sono rilassate e
proviamo allora da cosa inizia ad
iniziare da un cubetto di ghiaccio punto
eccolo qua stavamo un pochino sugli ad
odette che è abbastanza spesso
e un bel po spesso non contro un cubetto
quadrato dipende però sul computer fa
ragazzino comunque allora il trucco non
contrarlo quindi denti davanti nome
scientifico tenti di da santi
ero fresco allora terry per mille la
cosa insopportabile la faccia sulla
lingua sul palato piazzato che che altro
questa studi più un video estivo se ci
fossero 40 gradi sarebbe fantastica
mangiare il ghiaccio
adesso d'inverno quasi quasi piogge a
caldo quindi ci sta la vera prossimo
preghiamo un pezzo di odio che cos'è
questa è una carota che cos'è questa
secondo voi mi sembra una carota cosa si
faccia in una smoothie forse mango non
la fa
aspettiamo e vediamo se riesco a capirlo
passivamente summit lanci perché se un
po spuntato purtroppo punto perché fa
caldo oggi questa è un ananas
buona però mezzo scontata allora qua con
la super fragola spero che siamo ancora
bella non tanto me la farei davvero
non so perché mi ha dato più fastidio
questo è un po sconto rispetto alla
appunto di ghiaccio o carceri
allora andiamo con un altro cubetto che
si sono incontrati bello fresco
e continuiamo con un po di frutta ma da
tempo questa mini fragola sarà scontato
ma troppo
fatemi sapere nei colpi di vita sono
questi sogni per quali sono i suoni che
vi rilassano di più in assoluto
io ho scoperto guardando i video smr che
sapete che ognuno al proprio fratello
quindi nessuno che ti rilassa di più ha
scoperto che il mio twitter e che non
pensavo le forbici che tagliano i
capelli e purtroppo intrigherà
abbastanza raro avevo questo assolo dei
video tipo di persone non che tagliano i
capelli però cioè i loro capelli ma che
tagliano i capelli delle barbie tipo
della forbice che taglia i capelli che
consiglia di andare a sentirlo poi
fatemi sapere se dal teatro 4 rilassante
anche a voi comunque altro cubetto che
sei bella
oddio
[Musica]
continuiamo con un po di frutta perché
se scongelata così in fretta un brunch è
un po diverso questo scrivetevi anche i
commenti una domanda per voi perché
quella tv gsm r
ognuno ha delle motivazioni diverse
alcuni partono mia non riescono a
dormire alcuni se magari hanno un
interrogazione domani siete citati se
avete l'ansia oppure solo per farvi un
pochino
insomma scrivetemi pure il parco
l'attività semmai la sicurezza
un'altra sembra normale ma sono
prontissimi pro sicuro perfetti questa è
quasi secondo voi forse non me la
troviamo più difficile sentire il sapore
quando quando troppo folletto green i
commenti qual è il tuo furto preferito
il mio quando la piccola ad ora con la
mela grave mi piacciono un sacco ma mi
scoccia troppo così tempi chili da
spacciare
ogni volta è un casino per mangiare 4
picchi bisogna star lì sbucciare tutto e
quindi non sono più i miei frutti
preferite troppo complicati per
ultimamente c'è lotta sempre mi sono
sempre piaciuti tantissimo i mandarini
ne posso mangiare anche tipo 10 di fila
fanno benissimo e quindi si pensò i
mandarini sono i miei preferiti
scrivetelo nei commenti quale vostro
frutto preferito ultimi anche che oltre
a samarra volete che faccia magari non
sono mandando qualcosa
di specifico o o questo dopo con esse
mai più di una ragazza americana molto
brava thalis tali qualcosa praticamente
copriva al sun il microfono lo copriva
con una pellicola trasparente e poi
metteva sopra la schiuma da barba e poi
con il pennello tipo l'aspettano col
palermo con levità scolarità la spalmava
e faceva tutti questi sono poi si
sentivano benissimo quello perché là
sopra il microfono era fantastico
soprattutto di farlo anch'io ho paura di
fare un casino tipo e schermo da bar
mentre dentro microfoni loro miniero per
sempre cloud con focus micro anche
essere qualcosa di molto rilassata
insomma fatemi sapere se volete eterno
un'altra ma schettino di ghiaccio per
questo è finito e questa fortuna ormai
si è praticamente sciolta questo piaccia
questo è spessissimo non sono sicura se
sarò in grado di buongiorno perché
praticamente questa in realtà era una
formina per cioccolatini
quindi sono molto più spessi ecco qua
siate attenti alle dita ecco qua spesso
vedete quindi è tra l'altro è
freddissimo appena tolto dal freezer e
appunto di futuro sembra che mi fa
questa fonda questo bene
era molto gelido è stato più complicato
questo la professione di super sony
fatemi sapere se io non rilasciato
queste sony e non me la sento di
mangiare un altro perché tra i denti
zelig non mi ha fatto male i denti devo
dire però con quei denti inseriti quindi
direi che ne ho mangiato abbastanza tra
frutta conservata piaccio quindi fatemi
sapere se volete vedere un altro smr
simile è un altro smr genere o che tipo
di smr volete vedere e via sia una
cassettina in cui potete vedere i miei
altri pds mr altrimenti nelle altre
piazze linee potete vedere i miei altri
pt anormali
cliccate su quello che preferite e buona
visione